le gwenn aël qui est avec nous dans le
public est ce que vaut elle peut se
lever merci gonelle merci d'être avec
nous bonnel merci beaucoup ça bonsoir et
merci d'être là car il me disait tout à
l'heure que la violence france était de
plus en plus violente
c'est ce dont on parle depuis des mules
c'est vrai que la violence allait
partout et vous vous êtes la mère denis
16 ans tuée en juin 2019 êtes taxi
ambulance hier dans les côtes d'armor
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter ce
qui est arrivé à votre fils à mon fils
était menacé de mort depuis deux mois ci
parce qu'il avait voulu aider son
camarade c'est une histoire c'est
compliqué
son ami avait repéré une fille qu'il a
été déjà sorti quelques temps avant il
voulait ressortir avec don qui lui avait
envoyé un texto
mais cette fille là avait un petit ami
d'accord ce petit ami l'a très mal pris
il a commencé à envoyer des menaces à
l'ami de mon fils et il s'est pris de
peur donc qui lui a montré les messages
en disant qu'est-ce que je peux bien
faire et mon fils a pris le relais il a
pris le téléphone et il a appelé l'autre
élève pour lui dire écoute laisse
tranquille où mon ami il a compris elle
n'est pas allée pas tout seul il va la
laisser tranquille il a pu rester avec
mais ça a continué et il a reçu de
fortes menaces sur son téléphone
c'est à dire au delà des photos de
revolver en lui disant on va venir te
crever on va venir te faire la peau
on va te mettre dans un coffre de
voiture et te faire disparaître j'avais
pas les plantes
j'ai porté plainte à la gendarmerie de
matignon qui est à côté de chez moi
jusqu'à vous donner
ils m'ont dit que c'était des affaires
de gamins et des ados et que ça allait
pas aller bien plus loin
je mets qui il prenait quand même la
plainte parce que mon fils ce qu'il
voulait c'était pouvoir sortir dehors
sans avoir peur j'étais apprenti
boulanger ils allaient tous les matins 5
heures du matin à pied et il avait la
peur au ventre d'aller au travail et de
remonter tellement que ses collègues de
travail m'ont dit et je ne savais pas
j'ai se tartiner le visage de farine et
de chocolat pour remonter chez moi bon
être connu incroyable et ils l'ont
poursuivie alors bonjour 2019 en juin
2019 j'ai emmené mon fils au cfa
d'aucaleuc parce que il avait s'était
pas réveillé donc je vais emmener il y
aller à reculons et le soir à la sortie
des cours
un jeune a attendu dix minutes avant la
fin des cours la frapper par derrière
il est tombé une première fois il s'est
relevé il lui a dit que c'était une
histoire de gamins et que ça allait en
rester là
y a pas besoin d'en venir aux mains
parce que faut savoir qu'ils avaient
fait tout un stratagème pour tuer mon
fils il lui avait versé du chocolat dans
le casier le matin pour salir son
jogging auquel il tenait bon le mettre
en colère il est resté près d'une heure
dans une salle tout seul à être en
colère a tapé dans les casiers
parce que à la maison là bas un punching
ball c'est comme ça qu'il se calme mais
la tension est descendu donc il a pris
son sac à dos pour partir et le jeune ne
voulait pas en rester là
il lui a retapé une fois dessus par
derrière à la tête en faisant une prise
de kickboxing parce que c'est un
champion de bretagne de kick boxing
mon fils est tombé il a eu deux secondes
pour se relever mais il est retombé et
là il s'est mis dessus
il l'a frappée à la tête le médecin m'a
dit que il avait joué au foot avec sa
tête qu'il avait tiré sur plusieurs
mètres par les cheveux parce qu'il lui a
manqué il la miss heureux contre le
trottoir
il lui a mis quelques claques voyant
qu'il n'était il n'était plus en vie
qu'il ne bougeait plus il a essayé
peut-être et puis il s'est sauvé il a
pris sa mobylette
enfin sa petite moto et il est repassé
devant mon fils selon les témoignages
pour sourire devant mon fils il a fait
un grand sourire et il est reparti et
j'ai appris qu'il y avait une vidéo
on n'arrive pas à mettre la main dessus
parce que c'est sûr snapshot des jeunes
qui étaient avec lui ont filmé tout ce
qui s'était passé
juin 2000 le 24 juin 2019 devant son
la sortie des kouriles avec l âge aux
jeunes 16 ans il est incarcéré
aujourd'hui non il a fait de la garde à
vue il a été attrapé le soir même en
garde à vue parce qu'il y avait 22
témoins dont des professeurs d'école et
un gars fin de la garde à vue il a été
relâché parce que mon fils était dans le
coma mais pas décédée et ça a duré deux
jours
mon fils est décédé on la débrancher
parce qu'on m'a dit qu'il y avait trois
lésions irréversibles au niveau du
cerveau et qu'on ne pouvait plus rien
faire
mais pendant son hospitalisation il a
passé un irm et ils ont découvert annie
un anévrisme à l'arrière de la tête et
de là quand je suis passé devant la juge
la première fois avec mon avocat maître
philippe de veulent
la juge m'a annoncé que c'était
l'anévrisme qui avait tué mon fils est
pas les coups qu'il avait reçu donc ils
ont qualifié de violence ayant entraîné
une itt était de plus de huit jours
non si elle m'a dit que c'était la
qualification qui devait être donc nous
on a fait appel et a demandé une
contre-expertise cela contre expertise
est arrivé huit mois plus tard ça a été
en notre sens la violence est bien
responsable de la mort de mon fils ou de
la rupture mais à partie adverse a
demandé une autre expertise parce que à
l'hôpital j'aurais peut-être pas dû le
faire mais j'ai pensé procès j'ai
photographié monfils sur son lit pour
que l'on voit à quel point on l'avait
frappé mais comme il a été frappé par
derrière il n'a rien sur le visage il a
aucune trace et justement ils s'en
servent pour dire que comme n'y avait
pas de trace
ça n'était pas assez violent pour avoir
déclenché l'anévrisme et donc ils
partent sur quelles hypothèses commence
alors la jeune et aujourd'hui les
rouleaux jaunes
il est dehors il fait ses études
d'apprentis
il fait sa vie tranquillement je les
croisais il tête haute
ils se promènent devant parce qu'il a il
est à 200 m de chez l'ami à mon fils qui
est toujours menacée ils se promènent
devant chez lui avec sa famille en
souriant
comment comment voulez-vous donc quand
on entend des histoires comme ça vous
que la police puisse faire son travail
c'est par gaspard granger excusez moi je
m'adresse à vous parce qu'un journal de
la dame parce que jamais vous étiez où
le cas du président hollande la justice
ça fait des semaines et des semaines
qu'on dit il ya quand même un énorme
problème désoler mais les façons ce qui
est terrible c'est qu'on a pu on écoute
une histoire pareille on peut être qu'au
révolter moi je vois là on se dit qu'il
ya un problème énorme et on espère que
vous pouvez obtenir plus mais là
aujourd'hui nous avons encore espoir
d'obtenir justice où c'est fini alors là
la seconde expertise est encore dans
notre sens enfin quelques oeufs on
domine est celle que ils ont de ce fait
ils ont demandé dans notre sens
l'anévrisme a bien été rompues soit par
les coups soit par l'agression qu'elle
voit ça dans notre sens mais les faits
ne sont toujours pas requalifier ces
incroyables depuis le mois de février
j'ai une question à vous poser est ce
que les parents de ce jeune homme ce
qu'on parlait de l'éducation si vous
aussi vous contacter pour n'en parler
jamais rien ça aussi c'est lorsque je
voudrais préciser aussi lorsque je suis
allée au commissariat de la gendarmerie
de dinan après la mort de mon fils pour
apporter les affaires parce que on ne
m'a pas réclamer les affaires de mon
fils ni le téléphone portable ni les
vêtements qu'il portait sur lui c'est
moi qui les ai trouvés à l'hôpital et
qui les ai apporté à la gendarme et on
m'a dit il n'est pas nécessaire de
prendre un avocat
alors que la partie adverse avait déjà
pris un avocat
oui bruno pomart va revenir la justice
ça ça traduit aussi ce qu'on a entendu
tout à l'heure avec la réaction de la
justice par rapport au travail que fait
la police ya une le ministre de la
justice il faut savoir aujourd'hui a
diffusé une circulaire au juge je leur
demande à me prononcer écoutez bien ce à
des peines d'emprisonnement en fonction
de la capacité d'accueil carcéral là
c'est un signe
c'est ça veut dire aussi j'aime pas
comptable de façon globale est un des
meilleurs rosés sur la jetée mais je dis
pas que ça ne va pas je ne sais pas ce
que tu as fait mais faisons attention
aussi à protéger la justice que si on
nous remet totalement en cause l'idée
même de justice mais les jours mon cher
justice et dangereux à tort je t'invite
à dire ça j'ai commencé par dire ça et
j'espère que la justice va construire
des places de prison avec il ya plus de
condamner ces villas molex est affolant
sénat mais si reed a posé la question
volontairement et je pense
qu'effectivement madame a vécu un drame
s'arrête ni avec une âme un drame qui
quiconque inqualifiable et on ne peut
pas se mettre à la place de la dame
parce qu'elle a vécu un des seuls à
l'avoir vécu mais il a posé une question
est ce que vous avez eu de la part des
parents une démarche venant dit non ça
démontre au delà du drame et 5 y est
catastrophique
la déshumanisation de notre société et
dire que des parents sont même pas
capables de venir vous voir pau j'avais
dit dire quelque part partager la peine
vous dire qu'ils sont désolés que que
que il espère que que vous allez un euro
à faire votre deuil que les choses sont
compliquées que rien pas de nouvelles
comme si vous n'aviez pas vécu la
disparition de votre enfant exactement
knock des parents qui sont pas capables
d'aller voir d'autres parents qui ont
perdu un enfant alors que leur fils est
concernée est coupable ou pas coupable
vous votre intime conviction c'est qu'il
est c'est pas les petits bouts
convictionnels justice on ne va pas
statuer sur 20 mais pour l'instant vaut
vous ne m'avez pas vu un seul témoignage
de la part des pas c'est frappant de la
déshumanisation de notre société
quand je parlais d'une perte de repères
tout à l'heure donc d'une forme de
d'indifférence d'agressivité de 2 c'est
affolant et c'est ça qui est inquiétant
parce que si on perd c'est essentiel la
comment voulez vous que nous parviennent
pas des comportements barbares
si c'est essentiel la qui donne nous
prémunir du reste c'est essentiel la il
disparaît
s'étiole ça c'est le plus inquiétant
agathe voulait dire quelque chose oui
pour pour continuer ce que ce que
pointer du doigt karim défaut de
l'autorité parentale indéniable et
encore une fois ce cas le l'événement
tragique et un inqualifiable qui avec
madame on ne peut que en est bouleversée
et lui apporter un soutien très modeste
1 de petite échelle mais il ya aussi
peut-être un rôle d'éducation à l'école
qu'on a pas
on a en a qu'on n'a pas su le prendre ce
changement de paradigme dans l'évolution
de la société et comment les jeunes
allaient à l'école
interagissez entre eux avec les réseaux
sociaux internet le harcèlement etc
parce que la violence qu'a décrit madame
elle n'était pas seulement fille qu'elle
était extrêmement insidieuse elle était
derrière les écrans de téléphone elle
était dans les casiers
elles étaient entre texto sur snapshot
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est sur ces
biais là où personne n'a de prise la
police haussier complètement démunis on
a très peu de preuves on a du mal à la
justifier on a du mal à la faire
comprendre on qualifie cette histoire de
gamins où ils s'envoient des images de
revolver entreront serrée 1 mais en fait
non c'est extrêmement grave et ça l'est
poursuit
à l'époque je sais pas quelle époque
l'époque de mes parents peut-être de mes
grands parents
cette violence qui s'arrêtait à la
limite de la cour de récréation où ils
pouvaient se bagarrer un petit peu entre
eux elle se continue à la maison il
avait peur d'aller sur son lieu de
travail le matin quand il partait à 5h
du mat fait c'est une violence tellement
l'attend tellement pernicieuse que on
est complètement démuni face à gwenaëlle
tu voudrais vous remercier pour votre
témoignage soit et j'ai rêvé du québec
voilà les annales ce que vous avez dit
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de
rajouter quelque chose alors oui je
voudrais pas ce que vous savez que la
justice bas ça coûte très cher c'est
vrai je suis pas venu spécialement pour
ça mais on a créé un site justice pour
denis 22 sur facebook avec des cagnottes
paye pas les litchis parce que mon à
douala
o'connell g je vais vous occuper de vos
niveaux de l'avocat il faut directement
vers les équipements on verra ça
ensemble et on va suivre votre cagnotte
kitty mais je vais je vais vous donner
un contact est d'avoir choisi parce
qu'on a créés c'est vrai qu'il ya plein
de gens qui n'ont pas les moyens
voilà de prendre à la bocca on a créé un
site où voilà vous allez pouvoir avoir
un avocat gratuitement un avocat
vraiment chevronnés qui va pouvoir vous
aider
c'est un site qu'on a créé avec un ami
avocat un jeune avocat de de 26 ans et
on a des avocats vraiment voilà
dispositions qui sont extrêmement
chevronnés qui vont venir en aide et ça
vous coûtera voilà 0 je vous donner
toutes les informations
dd là dès la fin de l'émission et on va
s'occuper debout juste après
[Applaudissements]